Chinese business has penetrated big
parts of the US economy they control
much of it and many American companies
now have Chinese ownership Congressman
Matt Gaetz represents Florida he's
worried that a bailout will wind up
enriching the Chinese and helping the
Chinese government he joins us and
congressman tell us what your thanks for
coming tonight
tell us what your concern is and how you
plan to address it Radisson hotels AMC
movie theaters even the Waldorf Astoria
New York are controlled by China in
essence and I think we ought to restore
every American worker an American small
business before borrowing money from
China so that we can then give it to
China to then pay China back with
interest after the Chinese virus that
seems like a foolish thing that a great
nation would never do I've introduced
legislation to block bailouts to
corporations that are controlled by
China it's so obvious I can't even
believe it's not the law already they
unleash a pandemic on the world we wind
up sending them tax dollars why would
that be a controversial thing to propose
well look China has a lot of influence
and the companies that seek Chinese
investment also have that influence but
this is a time that we can actually put
America first the needs of our people
and our businesses this should be the
easiest time in the world to ensure that
we are making reinvestment in the
American economy and that we are not the
world's fools by borrowing money money
from a country in the bond market
recycling it back to them and then
charging the next generation of
Americans interest on that money we
cannot do that Congress should include
my know China act in the ultimate relief
package that seems very obvious one
quick thing before you go
according to Bloomberg reporter Steven
Dennis there's a major roadblock to
finishing the sentence coronavirus bill
Democrats want Planned Parenthood and
other abortion clinics to get bailout
dollars obviously they already received
Medicaid funding they're not at risk of
going over going under why I mean is
this real for one thing and there is a
yeah there was an applicants doing it
yeah there's a never-ending list of
these virtue signaling items that the
left is trying to tuck into this bill
Jim Clyburn who is a leader in the
Democratic House said we ought to you
use the coronavirus is an opportunity to
see through our vision for the country
can we just for a moment take a pause in
trying to socially engineer America and
actually get resources in the hands of
desperate Americans who are worried
about how to buy food and clothing for
their children last question
15 seconds Senator Richard burr hid what
he knew about Crona virus in the country
lied about it and saved his own
portfolio instead is he gonna stay in
the Senate do you think Richard burr is
a disgrace he should be removed as the
intelligence chairman immediately as a
result of this conduct and as
Republicans in the Trump era we have an
obligation to say that we do not want
corrupt acts to be associated with our
tribe and Republicans need to start
stepping up and speaking out because
what Richard Byrd did in the Senate
stock sell-off is not something that we
want our brand associated with yeah god
bless you for saying that I wish more
people had the clarity and the bravery
to say that Matt Gaetz great to see you
thanks so much